hier soir durant son allocution
télévisée le chef de l'état a fait
savoir que la réouverture des
établissements scolaires reprendrait
progressivement à partir du lundi 11 mai
prochain une réouverture qui concerne
les crèches les écoles les collèges et
les lycées à partir du 11 mai nous
rouvrirons progressivement les crèches
les écoles les collèges et les lycées
mais si cette annonce a soulagé certains
parents d'autres se demandent si cette
mesure est vraiment sans danger car on
sait depuis le début de l'épidémie que
les enfants sont des sujets
particulièrement à risque puisque
porteurs asymptomatiques du virus sans
compter que le 11 mai ni les restaurants
ni les cinémas ni les lieux publics ne
rouvriront leurs portes le gouvernement
estimant que ce serait trop dangereux un
double discours qui inquiète notamment
la fcpe
l'association des parents d'élèves
aujourd'hui la majorité des classes sont
extrêmement lourdes elle peut frôler
jusqu'à 30 35 élèves quelques fois
comment les cours vont se passer dans
ces conditions en respectant les gestes
barrière justement en chine c'est la
décision inverse qui a été prise par le
gouvernement
si tout le pays reprend petit à petit
son activité les écoles seront les
derniers endroits à rouvrir même chose
en corée du sud un pays particulièrement
exemplaire dans sa gestion de la crise
alors réouverture des écoles le 11 mai
dangereux ou sans risque
alors réouverture de certaines écoles le
11 mai dangereux ou sans risque en tout
dix écoles ces crèches ses écoles ses
lycées donc ces collèges donc c'est des
élèves donc de voir deux de doute plus
petit âge jusqu'à ddr2 20 20 ans parce
que parfois il ya des hauts et des bonis
c'est moi pareil ans en terminale
j'avais 28 ans donc forcément voilà il
ya des mecs c'est moi j'étais plus vieux
que le prof en terminale je le ramener à
la maison en voiture et monsieur
monsieur bourges un jeu le ramener donc
est-ce que c'est dangereux ou pas cette
affaire c'est la question que tout le
monde se pose avant d'avoir la réponse
des spécialistes jean paul hamon et
djiby mohamed j'aimerais avoir le
sentiment de notre équipe
rené malleville voilà oui parce que on
parlait des déchets des collèges et
l'école et marc demers que ça et je peux
te dire que moi j'ai mon petit fils qui
va au collège où t'as combien de
personnes de la famille faire c'est un
truc de fou
c'est une famille en or à chaque fois
qu'ils nous parlent et l'équitable l
eepad elle est pareil et martin la
deuxième le travail et les cuisines elle
dans le collège d'alma robert 800 élèves
des sections ce qu on oublie aussi c'est
que les le collège ma rose se situe juin
comme les autres il a fait éloigner des
cartes et des villes et à chaque sortie
de collège je tien shan deux terminaux
capables de le part ça on va en parler
dans un instant rené parce que là
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on soit sûr est
ce que c'est dangereux ou pas est-ce que
vous le sentez dot dangereux au point
d'histoire de matthieu delormeau
je trouve que c'est aberrant que c'est
dangereux on en train de se rendre
compte en ce moment et le président l'a
dit hier qu'on ne sait rien c'est pas
jim la m je pense qu'à me contredire
pour l'instant on sait pas si une fois
connues du virus
on peut leur filet ou pas on sait pas si
les enfants peuvent contribuer à la
circulation du virus ou pas on avait dit
que d'enfants seraient pas touchés on en
train de te rendre compte qu'à des
gamins de 16 ans les enfants de 5 ans
qui sont en train de mourir que
peut-être qu'effectivement ce virus va
toucher les enfants
soyons honnêtes on ne sait rien sur rien
la semaine dernière jean temps tu fumes
fils à papa tu fume depuis la manne en
train de prendre compte que t'es gros
sud at il dit que les hommes ont plus
que les femmes
chaque jour on découvre des choses et
ont renvoyé des gamins à l'école qui
même si éventuellement ne l'ont pas
seront porteurs et vont rentrer chez eux
et leur fils
parents ou grands parents mais on marche
sur les mains on ne sait rien tant qu'on
ne sait rien il ne faut rien faire alors
vraiment quel est ton fondamentaux mais
c'est seulement moi mon sentiment
souvenez quand on avait fait btp et
macro il avait parlé il avait arrêté la
france en dix ans l'école ça s'arrête
les enfants ne vont plus à l'école là il
avait décidé d'arrêter la france là il
veut remettre la france le 11 mai au
travail il est obligé de passer par
l'école à mon avis c'est pas pour moi il
ya des risques parce que comme l'a
expliqué mathieu cantin enfants ils
valent à l'école et qui va rentrer chez
lui qui a quelqu'un dans la famille kg
qui a des problèmes cardiaques ou cas du
diabète
comment tu expliques ça et comment tu
tiens 200 enfants dans une cour de récré
comment tu les tiens en classe comment
tu fais quand ils vont se laver les
mains
comment tu fais sacrifier les enfants
c'est c'est fou de penser ça ça veut
dire que tu envoies les enfants première
ligne mais si tu veut renvoyer les
parents au travail un moment donné il
est un des petits gestes il est obligé
d'envoyer les enfants à l'école pour que
les gens retournent travailler mon sac
ne dit pas bien je peux pas vous et
jean-michel meyrin ge il ya quelque
chose qui est pas logique du tout si on
ferme les cinémas parce que c'est des
chansons regroupées
nous les écoles c'est le même principe
on fermait reste on laisse les cantines
scolaires ouverts ces mêmes principes
donc on a l'impression qu'on sacrifie un
peu les enseignants on three une
garderie gratuite pour que certaines
personnes puissent retourner de
travailler est comme ça faire redémarrer
un peu d'économie reste cette
rationalité ou très court série très bon
devant une école parfois le matin c'est
plus de 1000 personnes qui sera sans
bien sûr il personne
on a tous vu ce panneau vous savez des
51 surgit ici traverse plus de 800
enfants et c'est vrai que la réalité en
primaire la réalité c'est ça c'est
comment le gouvernement peut dire on va
mettre 1000 personnes devant une école
mais personne sera contaminé son masque
sans rien c'est aberrant alors c'est fou
justement on a deux spécialistes avec
nous on a le docteur jean paul hamon
merci président des médecins de france
jean-paul en tout cas la première fois
que je vois c'est que je suis heureux
parce que je vois que vous allez mieux
vous avez été couché touché par kobe de
19 il ya quelques jours
et plus ça va plus vous reprenez les
couleurs et plus je trouve que vous
allez mieux donc déjà ça c'est ma
première satisfaction on a des bonnes
nouvelles aujourd'hui après la spa
après les vingt mille euros voilà eh ben
on à jean paul hamon quéquette en
fanfare à jean-paul très bien ça merci
jean paul qu'est ce que vous pensez donc
vous
président des médecins de france de
cette mesure d'envoyer donc tous les
enfants à l'école le 11 mai et on fait
on lève tous fermés mais on résout les
écoles est-ce que c'est dangereux ou pas
je trouve que le président a bien dit
quand même que ce serait une réouverture
progressive mais ce matin et ce matin on
a vu quand même que monsieur blanc caire
a un petit peu préciser les choses
ça va être très très progressif ça va
être très ciblé et à mon avis ça va se
faire extrêmement lentement ils vont pas
prendre le risque de refaire ce plan b
l'épidémie alors que on est encore un
mois dans un an dans sais pas ce qui va
se passer dans vaillant mais on a une
épidémie qui continue d'être très active
on a vu qu'il ya davantage de personnes
qui sont hospitalisées
même s'il ya moins de réanimation qui se
moque c'est ça laisse un peu vert donc
si vous moi ce que je trouve important
actuellement c'est de continuer là
confiné pour donner de l'air aux
réanimateur qui depuis hier et demi sont
complètement débordés et font des
miracles pour faire marcher ses 7000 de
réanimation alors que l'on avait que 5
millions pour peu de temps
trouve que bon le petit nom il a été pas
mal il est honnête manger suffisamment
les suffisamment critiqué pour pour dire
que son intervention a été remarquable
hier il a été il a d'abord fait un mea
culpa et je pense que son administration
a bien entendu qu'elle n'avait pas été à
la hauteur il nous assurer qu'il y
aurait des mesures qui seraient prises
et je peux vous dire qu'on va garder le
souvenir de ça et puis il a été
extrêmement empathique à l'égard de
toutes les personnes qui se sont
engagées dans la défense dans la défense
de justement dans la lutte contre le coc
vide il a oublié quand même une
catégorie de personnes ce sont les
auxiliaires de vie
ils maintiennent et les assistantes
maternelles aussi et qui maintiennent et
qui maintiennent dans de bonnes
conditions les personnes âgées
dépendantes à leur domicile et
et actuellement si ça flambe les décès
malheureusement dans les ehpad à
domicile on se rend compte que les
personnes âgées dépendantes s'en tire
pas mal donc là sur les écoles c'est la
seule chose où je trouve qu'il a été un
petit peu imprudent parce qu'ils ont à
couvrir le risque de en plein le risque
de leur faire ça n'arrête pas je vous le
dis ça n'arrête pas de réagir
le virus est toujours en circulation il
est partout donc pas d'école je vous le
dis je n'en verrai jamais mon enfant à
l'école
cette reprise le 11 mai c'est
inconscient c'est à nous les parents à
ne pas mettre nos enfants à l'école
ouverte ou pas c'est nous qui décidons
il y aura plus de monde dans une école
que dans un restaurant les touristes
seront pas là mais le danger va être
dans les établissements scolaires voilà
perso monsieur mac on peut dire ce qu'il
veut je n'enverrais pas mon enfant à
l'école si la situation n'a pas changé
aux dernières nouvelles on va surtout
sacrifier les familles pauvres on
commencerait par les zones rurales et
quartiers populaires pour le retour à
l'école ça on sait pas du tout c'est le
ch a piqué son bras attends attends rené
deux secondes je voudrais avoir l'avis
jimmy mohamed
est-ce que c'est dangereux pour toi ou
pas cette reprise de l'école voilà parce
que ça soit écouté il ya plein de gens
qui lisent
mine de rien ça veut dire quoi c'est à
dire que j'ai envoyé mon enfant parce
que ce qu'est ce qu'il a dit hier le le
président a dit que les enfants
n'étaient pas touchés par le kobe 2009
c'est à dire qu'il pouvait la voir mais
qui n'avaient pas de symptômes et que
c'était pas grave pour eux mais mignon
ainsi vont à l'école il quand ils vont
revenir le soir si loin ils vont
peut-être le ramener à la maison et
contaminer leur part leur père ou leur
mère
donc c'est cher la question que tous se
posent les gens qui travaillent aussi
dans les écoles les instituteurs tous
les ponts ils vont pouvoir peut-être
être contaminée qui étudia ça diminue
alors c'est une situation qui est très
compliqué et bien malin sera celui qui
pourrait expliquer ce qui va se passer
au 11 mai on sait tous trompés beaucoup
trompé et de faire une prévision sur ce
qui va arriver dans un mois je pense que
c'est très compliqué et là on vit une
période assez extraordinaire en perte de
koudougou coupe du monde vous avez ce
ressenti de milan sélectionneur est
désormais on à 66 millions de
spécialistes en épidémiologie les
jean-michel de la virologie qui tout
d'un coup nous explique d'où vient le
virus alors que nous n'en savons rien
c'est la seule vérité
à l'heure actuelle et ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que on parlait de
confinement on offre les perspectives de
déconfinement et dès lors qu'on offre
une date on a l'impression que c'est
l'apocalypse et qu'on va sacrifier les
enfants c'est absolument pas le cas le
jour d'après c'est non
jr d'une nouvelle épidémie une fois
qu'on va sortir du confinement
il ne faudra pas oublier que le virus
continuera de circuler et qu'à partir de
ce moment là il faudra dire avec lui
brise pendant de nombreuses semaines
voire nombreux mois ce qui veut donc
dire que les enfants dans les écoles
oui sont un vecteur de la maladie on ne
sait pas dans quelle proportion
exactement on est absolument incapable
de dire combien de pourcentage des
élèves sont porteurs sains
asymptomatiques s'ils ont été immunisés
ou pas on n'en sait strictement rien
tout ce qu'on sait c'est que des
professeurs ont été malades dans l'oise
et que à ce moment là il faudra
peut-être protéger les profs et
rappelez-vous qui est aussi une
disparités très importantes entre les
écoles du grand est de l'île de france
et puis si vous regardez ce qui se passe
dans le sud ouest dans les landes vous
avez une vingtaine de malades qui est
hospitalisée donc dans un mois la
situation épidémique se racontait
beaucoup plus stable et propice à une
réouverture des écoles puisque l'enjeu
est peut-être l'économique permettre aux
parents de retravailler et à ce moment
là des enfants à l'école mais l'idée
malgré tout et elle n'est pas totalement
stupide c'est celle qui consiste à dire
et même si on a eu des cas les drames
chez des enfants
globalement depuis le début de
l'épidémie les enfants sont peu voire
pas touché par le cojones virus même
s'il ya eu des drames des enfants de 16
ans des jeunes y en a eu mais dans
l'immense majorité des cas c'est plutôt
des personnes qui sont un peu plus âgés
que les enfants donc le risque qu'on
fait courir aux gens on considère qu'il
est peut être faible et au bout d'un
moment de toute façon cette question
laurent victoire des écoles on l'aura le
1er septembre ce sera exactement la même
chose donc de toutes façons la réelle
question qu'il faut se poser c'est sûr
nous prêts à affronter l'épidémie
les mesures que nous allons prendre à
partir du 11 mai c'est celle qu'on
aurait dû prendre probablement au tout
début de l'épidémie mais que nous
n'avons pas pu prendre car la chine a
démasqué laisse les chiffres et on a
sous-estimé l'ampleur de l'épidémie
ce qui veut donc dire que normalement si
on a des masques si on a des tests si on
a du gel on devrait être en mesure enfin
de contrôler l'épidémie pour lui a évité
une deuxième vague trop haute qui soyons
honnêtes va arriver il va falloir
apprendre à vivre avec le virus
il va falloir apprendre à avoir des cas
pendant des semaines et des semaines et
l'ouverture aux écoles n'est qu'après
alors jean paul hamon
jean paul minn on va quoi on va aller à
l'école avec on veut envoyer nos enfants
à l'école avec des masques et des gants
même les plus petits c'est que c'est
quoi c'est quoi le truc non mais il va
falloir là il vient de très bien dire ce
qui va se passer il va falloir apprendre
à vivre avec ce virus
il va falloir apprendre à vivre avec des
masques avec avec du gel avec une
distanciation sociale qui va peut-être
pouvoir s'améliorer s'ils ont réussi à
contrôler cette épidémie mais clairement
le 11 mai ce sera pas la fin d'épidémie
on va rentrer peut-être si l'épidémie
est contrôlé on va peut-être rentrer
dans une dans une nouvelle phase mais
les gens sont tous informés mais il va
falloir apprendre à vivre avec ce virus
et je pense sincèrement que il va
falloir protéger des enseignants on sera
peut-être l'école différemment tout ça
si vous voulez on mettra peut-être enfin
du savon dans les toilettes des écoles
vous savez pas ce que le savon au delà
comme ça la comprend lac est horrible à
fond la supplie il va falloir apprendre
il va falloir apprendre à vivre avec ce
virus et on voit malheureusement que la
chaleur ne ne fait rien sur ce virus et
c'est quelque chose qui va se passer
c'est que pendant les six mois qui
viennent avec les beaux jours qui
reviennent les autres virus hivernaux
vont disparaître donc les les
hospitaliers les médecins vont être
soulagés parce qu'il y aura moins de
pathologie et et mais il va falloir
apprendre avec ce virus c'est un sujet
qui déchaîne les passions dangereux ou
pas la reprise de l'école le 11 mai il
ya énormément de réactions vous
continuez à réagir
regardez réouverture des écoles 11 mai
87 % des gens pensent que c'est
dangereux jean michel maire c'est
peut-être une question débile mais
campagne pour le climat il va falloir
s'habituer à vivre avec davantage de
tempêtes ouragans de tempête est ce que
là pour l'aider russe c'est pareil
falloir s'habituer ce que bientôt il est
commis de le govic 20021 de plus en plus
de virus comme ça qu'ils vont être
mortelles comme ça pour la société jimmy
woo jean-paul mon arrivée on l'écouté là
il ya des études des projections qui
explique que les mesures de distance à
sion sur ce elle devrait peut-être être
prolongé jusqu'en 2021
voire 2022 et certaines études montrent
jusqu'à 2025 pour faire disparaître le
kobe de 19 ce ne sont que
les projections projection veut pas dire
qu'il y avoir de nouveaux virus
émergents mais que peut-être que ce
virus
on va avoir énormément de mal à s'en
débarrasser et quand on entend
l'histoire des écoles on parle on dise
que les enfants vont mettre des masques
que non allez expliquer à un enfant 3 4
ans qu'il faut mettre un masque mais il
faut pas toucher son voisin c'est
traumatisant
imaginez une enfance on va vous dire
surtout nos noms ne touche pas à ton
comme un contrat à sa camarade surtout
attention mets pas tes mains à la bouche
les enfants impossible on observe une
certaine innocence qu'il faut préserver
c'est terrible ce que je vous dis mais
le savon dans les toilettes
mettez en tant que vous voulez le virus
continuera de circuler un enfant ça ne
fait pas attention c'est le principe des
enfants on pourra peut-être éduquer un
peu plus les collégiens les lycéens et
pour les tout petits
il ne faut pas les traumatismes ça il ya
quelqu'un qui loue discret logo je
voudrais savoir g de l'asthme est-ce que
c'est dangereux pour moi d'aller au
collège jimmy écouter tout ce qui est
pathologies respiratoires semble plus à
risque de complications même si on n'est
pas encore été sûr on pense que c'est
plutôt le tabac et les personnes qui ont
des bronchites chroniques donc pour
l'instant on pense que plutôt non mais
attention jusqu'à collégiens collégiens
un collégien de 11 ans est pas tout à
fait aussi à risque un collégien de 15
ans jusque quand on grandit plus on se
rapproche des adultes edwards 15 ans je
le sens bien 15 saisons donc voilà
quelle hypocrisie le gouvernement veut
simplement relancer l'économie point
barre mais ils vont s'en mordre les
doigts qu'est ce que vous répondez à sa
jean paul hamon il ya sûrement une
petite arrière pensée il pour remettre
quelques parents au travail
c'est vrai que on a déjà vu passer des
consignes jésus un architecte en
consultation une heure qui m'a montré
les consignes pour les reprise des
chantiers dans le bâtiment ces
recommandations sont pas idiote
on pourra certainement faire repartir
quelques parties dépit des quelques
parties de l'économie en prenant des
précautions c'est sûr mais si on
recommence à mettre du monde dans les
transports en commun si on revoit les
écoles c'est sûr qu'on n'est pas sorti
serai je disais une blague tout à
l'heure la lave le plus dur le plus dur
branche confinement cesser la première
année mais mais c'est vrai que quand
j'entendis vibrera bêtes qui nous dit
qu'on achetait 2022 2025
il ya des gens qui vont se suicider du
il faut faire attention à ce qu'on dit
l'offre hors option
non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il
faut garder le moral je pense à tous ces
gens qui sont soucieux de garder le
moral aussi les chéris c'est extrêmement
important ça vraiment et c'est pour ça
qu'on essaie d'être avec vous aussi tous
les soirs de vous accompagner
il ya il ya mathieu delormeau qui veut
dire un truc et il ya le directeur
général de la santé donc monsieur
salomon qui a indiqué que toutes les
personnes malades pourront être testés
d'ici au 11 mai donc ça aussi ça joue
dans la réouverture des écoles 1
forcément ça qui me et jean paul bril
oui oui oui mais attention quand on
parle de dépistage de masse on a
l'impression qu'on va tester 66 millions
de français n'auriez pas clown à l'aller
lorsqu'on parle des dépistages
imaginez même une capacité de 100 mille
tests par jour ce qui est énorme nous
dit qu'on va atteindre sa avoir 200
milles mais si vous prenez sans me teste
si vous voulez tester juste l'île de
france c'est à dire 12 millions de
personnes
il va me falloir sans un jour on pourra
pas testé tout le monde tout le temps
donc on fera des cibles et peut-être que
les professeurs devront faire partie ses
cibles peut-être qu'on devra tester
l'entourage de personnes malades mais la
personne qui n'aura pas de symptômes
soyons honnêtes ne pourra pas être testé
car on n'a pas assez de test on pourra
pas testé aussi massivement qu'on le
voudrait et c'est vrai que c'est la
grande question du jour est ce que c'est
dangereux pas vous êtes 87 % à penser
que ces dangereuses et il ya des
questions qui arrive à jimmy vous a
demandé il ya une personne qui dit sa
fille a dû elle à du diabète
voilà et elle va être elle va rentrer au
lycée est ce que c'est dangereux ou pas
qu'elle gagne bonjour alors pour
l'instant ce qu'on considère c'est que
les personnes qui seraient plus à risque
c'est les diabétiques plutôt de type 2
c'est à dire ceux qui ont un diabète y
est ko
le débat est un peu de la vieillesse du
surpoids débat du diabète de type 1
sûrement qui touche plutôt les enfants
qui seraient sous insuline et ca serait
plutôt un adepte de type 2 sert des
plats des médicaments et un diabète
plutôt déséquilibrée avec en plus
d'autres pathologies comme de
l'hypertension ou du surpoids
on va parler peut-être juste après et
donc a priori pourrait y aurait quand
même moins de risques que pour une autre
personne âgée
en revanche attention peut-être qu'à
deux enfants comparables elle est
peut-être plus à risque où il faut qu'au
centre prudents parce qu'encore une fois
on s'est beaucoup trompé je pense qu'il
faut faire très attention et peut-être
qu'elle sera partie des enfants qu'il
faudra peut-être ne pas mettre à l'école
tout de suite en tout cas
surveiller de façon plus rapproché si
peut-être ceux qui on devra faire des
tests sérologiques pour savoir si par
chance elle l'a c'est peut-être déjà eu
alors il ya quelqu'un qui le dit
ça me fait doucement rire la polémique
sur le retour des enfants à l'école
quand je vois le nombre de pseudo
sportive courir en groupe le soir à
partir de 19h bon c'est vrai que ça
c'était une petite blague ans il ya
plein de gens qui sont devenus des
spécialistes du jogging depuis le
coronavirus depuis le confinement ça
c'est assez drôle
laurence ça y est j'ai vraiment votre
avis en tant que ex mine de rien
représentants du parti de république à
ce que vous comprenez cette décision est
ce que vous auriez pris la même décision
vous déjà comprendre cette décision on
est en moi je comprends aussi des
inquiétudes et c'est pour ça qu'il va
falloir beaucoup expliqué et comme dit
muhammad me disait de toute façon
malheureusement on va être obligés
d'apprendre arrive avec ce virus parce
qu'il faut quand même savoir que le
confinement
c'est pas le remède contre le virus le
confinement qui est obligatoire et
suivre strictement bien sûr pour le
moment il est destiné à aplanir les pid
et sopat à un pic
il n'aurait pas pu être absorbés par
l'aria mais malheureusement que ce soit
dans un mois dans deux mois ou dans
trois mois il y aura toujours
évidemment ce virus et si jamais il y
avait en septembre ou octobre
un pic du virus avec en même temps le
retour d'autres pathologies lumier à
l'arrivée de légères la grippe c'est
aussi et enfin je pense qu'il ya eu
rapport qui ont démontré que les
patients asymptomatiques était moins
contagieux et c'est ça aussi qui a
convaincu le président de la république
de commencer par les écoles